the coronavirus death toll is still
rising as you know we'll get you up to
date on that just a second but first
Anthony as you know there's another
serious threat we need to focus on right
now yeah Gayle there if the virus wasn't
enough there's some very dangerous
weather that could affect more than 89
million Americans today one powerful
storm pushing toward the East Coast
killed at least seven people in
Mississippi and one in Arkansas on
Easter Sunday possible tornadoes from
that system caused heavy damage in the
Tennessee Valley late last night
our affiliate WGCL reports at least six
more people were killed in Georgia
overnight
mark Strassmann reports on the
destruction in the south Chattanooga is
a scene of destruction lives tossed in
the middle of the night compromising
stay at home orders issued over the
pandemic that grips the nation
Mississippi was already in a state of
emergency to fight the virus and
declared another on Sunday in the wake
of devastating tornadoes there in total
up to 46 tornadoes were reported across
the south Sunday one of them slammed the
city of Monroe Louisiana damaging
hundreds of buildings I heard this
really loud bang and now it's like okay
well the windows gone but I didn't
expect this type of destruction the
widespread damage comes as several
public shelters have closed nationwide
to stop the spread of the virus but it's
complicated as officials still encourage
people to seek refuge in shelters like
this one all while following social
distance guidelines in Alabama the
governor urged shelters to stay open and
even ease some of the state's
coronaviruses restrictions after our
tornado reportedly injured at least
three people on the Walker Jefferson
County Line and in Arkansas storms
brought some nasty storm clouds strong
winds and heavy rains fell on this house
sending an uprooted tree through the
roof of this home in Hot Springs and
causing one fatality in Jefferson County
for CBS this morning
I'm mark Strassmann and unfortunately
the severe weather threat is not over
Lonnie Quinn chief weather caster at our
New York station wcbs-tv is tracking all
the storms today Lonnie good morning so
who's in the crosshairs today okay right
now Tony we're talking about tornado
watches anywhere from the panhandle of
Florida all up the eastern seaboard to
portions of Virginia and I wouldn't be
surprised if that tornado watch push a
little further north as the day went on
so what's the culprit here you look at
the low level jet stream the low level
jet stream it's flowing at around 120
miles per hour and it's important to
talk about the low level jet because
that's air that's less than 10,000 feet
from the surface and all it takes is a
little piece to drop down the worst of
it right now around the Carolinas by the
time you get to say lunchtime it's into
the Chesapeake by the time we get to
4:00 p.m. it's to New York City so we're
not talking sustained winds right we're
talking these gusts and even the
possibility for more tornadic activity
as we push through this day wind alerts
and this is something else the red is
the most serious all right those are
high wind warnings that's where it's
most likely to find the power outages
but all the areas shaded in tan those
are still wind advisories so nearly half
of all Americans are under some kind of
a wind alert today and I want to show
you that in the Northeast at least we
always fear that word a nor'easter this
is not a nor'easter all right this is a
southeastern and those air that air is
coming in from the south
wind flowing in from the south and east
so it's pushing it on shore pulling
around places like the South Shore of
Long Island where there could be some
coastal flooding as well my one tip for
you I do that there will be power
outages turn your refrigerator and
freezer down to the lowest setting right
now in case you lose power let's go back
to you gale man Lonnie the last thing we
need is bad weather but thank you for
letting us know what's coming